este edificio en el oeste de Ucrania se
ha transformado en un centro de
detención para prisioneros de guerra
rusos estos hombres fueron apresados por
las tropas ucranianas en plena batalla y
algunos tienen graves heridas de guerra
en febrero y sufrió una emboscada allí
perdí la pierna
se supone que actualmente hay varios
cientos en la prisión pero se desconocen
las cifras oficiales los detenidos
tienen derecho a dos horas de televisión
al día con noticias ucranianas
no entiendo nada las autoridades rusas
nos decían una cosa y acá escucho lo
contrario intento compararlo pero no hay
nada Claro los funcionarios ucranianos
se mantienen firmes en que de acuerdo
con la convención de Ginebra los
detenidos son tratados con dignidad y
respeto a los derechos humanos y cuando
se preguntó a los prisioneros por sus
condiciones Si la presencia de la
seguridad reafirmaron que son bien
tratados e incluso se les permite Llamar
a sus familias en ocasiones todos ellos
hablaron de irse con suerte mediante un
intercambio de prisioneros entre los dos
países
le dije a mi madre que estoy bien y sano
pero que espero desesperadamente que me
intercambien no quiero que se preocupe
demasiado
estos dos hombres en la enfermería
tienen 20 y 21 años el primero perdió
las dos piernas por una mina terrestre
en el frente y dice que fue operado y
atendido por los ucranianos
No tengo ánimo Pero tengo que aguantar
cada día tengo que volver a aprender
cosas
espero conseguir una prótesis y que la
vida pueda empezar de nuevo
la cruz roja ha visitado la prisión pero
aún no ha publicado sus conclusiones
Aunque hay otros centros de detención
para prisioneros rusos en toda Ucrania
donde se desconocen sus condiciones